à coignières qui a connu trois maires
depuis 2014 et une élection municipale
partielle qui a installé didier fischer
comme maire il y a un an la campagne du
scrutin se lancent peu à peu premiers
candidats officiellement déclarés c'est
xavier girard bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes trésorier du comité des
fêtes de la commune vont conduire et la
liste sans étiquette coignard à venir
c'est une association d'habitants à la
base un qui a été créée en 2018 au
moment de l'opposition sur le projet de
fusion avec mort pas pourquoi créer
cette association à l'époque
au départ c'était vraiment un collectif
de citoyens qui qui étaient horrifiés de
ce qui est arrivé à leur ville leur
village et il avait touché à leurs
valeurs et là à ce moment là bas on a
créé ce collectif qui était l'union de
tous les démocrates et tous les
républicains
pour nous c'était une infamie de revenir
sur nos repas en tout cas de faire cette
union sans nous concerter et un projet
qui a été ensuite abandonnés du coup
c'était là juste suite de proposer cette
liste là pour ces élections municipales
de faire un petit a fait ça mais j'en
fais partie donc beaucoup de policiers
des secousses a résonné notre notre
devoir de faire quelque chose en fait ça
a réveillé le citoyen qui était en nous
et se dire que on ne pouvait pas se
laisser maniées par des politiques il se
passait des choses en derrière nous on
ne comprendrait pas tout et on a envie
d'agir voilà alors pourquoi dira bien
qu'il ya la volonté d'être apolitique ça
veut dire qu'il n'y a pas de
revendication d'investiture ça ça va
rassembler diverses sensibilités cette
liste là on essaie d'aller au plus large
de la droite de la gauche les
écologistes une seule ce critère qui a
un mais diable on ne veut pas d'extrême
donc on peut être encarté on peut être
encarté il ya plusieurs personnes qui
sont à différents partis
qui sont engagés politiquement depuis
plusieurs années parfois ça ne constitue
pas un problème c'est juste la diversité
on veut que toutes ces différences face
à différents c'est notre second donc
voilà on parlait du projet de fusion qui
a été apporté aux rappels qui a entraîné
une large défection de la majorité à
l'époque et est conduit à la démission
de jean-pierre sevestre en septembre
2010 8,3 mer en six ans à coignières une
année 2018 finalement mouvementée est ce
que depuis l'élection de didier fischer
d'une certaine sérénité qui revenue dans
cette commune on le rappelle moins de
4500 habitants
est ce que c'est votre avis et ça a été
très difficile pendant quatre ans avec
tous les projets qui ont été bloqués
dont qui ont avorté qui ont été
reportées pour certains donc là
effectivement d'avoir un maire depuis un
an avec une équipe municipale
ça apporte en plus c'est certain que ça
ne change depuis les deux trois
dernières années maintenant une certaine
sérénité oui retrouver c'est pas pour
autant qu'il faut rester vigilant et on
est dans le challenge de l'équipe de
monsieur fisher est ce que la création
par exemple de conseils de quartier qui
a été une initiative du maire actuel
indiqué fisher est ce que c'est une
initiative qui va dans la bonne voie
vous qui prônez justement une liste
citoyenne est ce que les le citoyen doit
avoir son mot à dire dans la décision
politique d'une commune on parlait
enfants police tous les deux et puis
avec ma colistière qui était avec moi
petit monde
on a participé ces comités de quartier
ça revient d'une bonne décision on pense
de l'équipe en place
après je les 10 en fin de conseil
municipal monsieur fisher
personnellement j'ai été un petit peu
frustré des suites puisque en fin de
compte ce qui revient principalement
c'est des problèmes de voirie des
problèmes d'éclairage des problèmes de
propreté
la plupart seront retrouvés en périmètre
de la sky et on n'a pas de visibilité
quant aux suites et sinon davantage à
améliorer en tout cas ces six sur la
codification effectivement des suites à
donner mais en tout cas oui au départ ça
vient démocratie participative avec les
citoyens plutôt en plus c'était plutôt
bien géré avec des grosses
participations lens on parle de votre
programme il reposera sur quatre piliers
la famille d'abord comment comptez vous
agir sur ce sujet de la famille alors
famille on va reprendre surtout aussi de
l'intergénérationnel
on va reprendre de la petite enfance à
la séniorité on pense créer certaines
choses comme la pass mobilité pour un
handicap également pour les jeunes
enfants c'est compliqué d'avoir une
poussette traversée traversée coignières
actuellement on a des trottoirs qui sont
qui sont défoncées c'est une certaine
dangerosité également on pense également
créer ainsi un city park était déjà dans
le programme de l'année dernière un
skate park
un nouvel espace de jeu dans la
résidence où il n'y en a pas voilà un
certain nombre de choses comme ça
évidemment avec la participation des
enfants aussi à résidence et personnes
âgées
on a beaucoup d'idées ans dans le
domaine un volet environnement aussi est
ce que vous êtes favorable à ces
demandes de la munition municipalité
d'intégrer le parc naturel régional de
la haute vallée de chevreuse coignières
pourrait l'intégrer et ce dès 2023 comme
ville port c'est à dire un statut de
villes membres finalement ce cas c'est
une première c'est une première étape
vers l'intégration totale
il faut aller en ce sens il faut faire
partie du pnr pourquoi n'y a je pense
qu'il faut partir fois reparti du pnr
comme gilles porte compliqué d'aller
plus loin puisqu'on n'a qu'à une énorme
zone commerciale et industrielle et puis
la fameuse nationale 10 ce qui nous
fonde mais entre saint-rémy l'honorer le
mesnil saint denis qui font partie du
pnr on se trouve là entre deux et on a
des très très beaux espaces qui sont les
bois dit dassault on a le temps d'une
valve favery on a des gens qui sont
maintenant tous bio donc on a notre
place au sein du pnr un volet sécurité
aussi alors la majorité actuelle est
revenu sur la police intercommunale qui
avait été créée sous la majorité de jean
pierre sauvestre une police
intercommunale avec maurepas et est-ce
que c'était une mauvaise décision et ce
qu'il fallait la conserver cette police
intercommunale et je le lui dirai qu'au
départ je trouvais que c'était une bonne
décision
le fait qu'on a une police
intercommunale parce que ça permettait
de mutualiser les moyens
donc les notamment avec une présence le
samedi maintenant qu'on a
police qui est revenu dans notre giron
on a des plannings évidemment plus
étroit la municipalité actuelle a voulu
se doter d'une police plus importante
est passé de cette fonctionnaire à douze
fonctionnaires en tout cas sur la liste
des effectifs
ça peut permettre de faire des choses
intéressantes maintenant c'est pas
encore réellement en place
on n'a pas encore les effectifs on n'a
pas encore de retour mais par contre oui
effectivement
le fait d'avoir douze fonctionnaires ça
permettrait de faire des actions
pédagogiques n'est pas que de la
répression
et ça pourrait être intéressant idem
pour les pompiers on a deux pompiers
dans la lys et ils sont assez connus là
dessus pour leur action
on pourrait faire des actions notamment
au sein des écoles enfin le dernier
volet c'est l'économie coignard et et
fait également de zones commerciales les
portes de chevreuse forum gibet et par
ios 5 est limitrophe qui est sûre située
sur la commune de maurepas saint quentin
en yvelines a lancé une réflexion autour
de cette zone commerciale vieillissante
est ce qu'il faut aller en ce sens qu'il
faut réfléchir à une nouvelle stratégie
pour cette zone commerciale
c'est connu de tout le monde sait que le
modèle actuel avait enfin le modèle
commercial accueille lille arrive en fin
de vie donc on a des grands espaces qui
mon petit à petit être des friches
ça commence déjà donc il faudra adapter
l'ensemble des espaces et notamment il
n'y a pas que ça il ya également les
petits commerces constitue un vrai souci
sur coignard on a beaucoup de grandes
surfaces
on a trois gros porteurs d'ailleurs qui
se porte pas très bien et on a besoin
d'un espace commerce au sein du village
donc on y pense également à créer au
coeur du village un espace qui permet de
redynamiser le village qui commence à
être un peu vieillissant avec une
résidence des résidences qui sont nés
entre les années 80-90 sur ce sujet par
exemple des zones commerciales ça
implique un travail forcément avec
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines il est ce qu'il faut renforcer
les liens avec l'agglomération quelle
est votre position c'est juste
nécessaire clairement
ils ont vraiment les cartes en main
comme vous savez dans une commune plus
de 50% on revient maintenant du pirée m
la communauté d'agglo et ses surfaces
commerciales vu la surface que ça
représente un corner c'est juste
nécessaire indispensable de travailler
avec les instances de rallye sur des
sujets comme le carrefour de la maldonne
y ait une concertation publique qui est
en cours actuellement
peut être aussi sur une requalification
de la nationale 10 on sait que le maire
actuel souhaiterait un enfouissement
comme c'est en projet à trappes il faut
travailler sur ce genre de projet pour
amal me donne alors le plaisir d'y aller
tout à l'heure pour pour la reine une
clôture
effectivement il faut redéfinir la
nationale 10 en tant que telle elle me
coupe la ville en deux il ya un gros
projet sur le quartier de la guerre une
redéfinition ça peut être l'objet de le
faire un an fournissent un enfouissement
et puis le fait de faire des voies
pédestres ou cyclistes nous permettent
d'aller d'un quartier à l'autre
effectivement un dernier mot il nous
reste à peu près 20 secondes les
derniers les prochains part dans les
prochains rendez vous est ce que vous
avez des rendez-vous les réunions
publiques en janvier on va faire deux
ateliers participatifs sur nos têtes on
a déjà un certain un certain nombre
d'idées on va les challenges et
vis-à-vis des citoyens et puis qui m'ont
des réunions publiques mois de mars
avant des élections
merci à xavier girard tête de liste de
coignières à venir et je précise que
vous êtes donc le premier candidat
déclaré officiellement dans cette
commune où le maire sortant didier
fischer devrait être également en lice
pour un nouveau mandat